[Música]
oi
os temas que o boi da ilha e hoje serão
o lixo a poluição do ar
a poluição da água a degradação do solo
o desmatamento e escassez de água
vocês estão tendo essa imagem vocês
sabem o que é isso é um ateu
quando nós consumimos os alimentos nós
temos que descartá lo de alguma forma e
os aterros são a melhor forma de
descartá lo pois lá o sol ele é
preparado para receber esse tipo de
resíduo mas tem um porém
lá tem muitos gases e quando o gás
metano se junta a esses outros gases
eles destroem a camada de ozônio e
poluiu a outros poluentes do ar são as
indústrias que soltam a sua os gases
químicos poluição da água a poluição da
água é quando você descarta de forma
errada e esse lixo vai parar nos rios
nos oceanos e nos mares
ele não só atrapalha o meio ambiente mas
também na vida animal e vegetal que nem
aconteceu com essa tartaruga que quando
eu era bebê e ela entrou nas argolas de
coca cola e elas cresceu com essa
deformidade no casco
nós não só interferimos na vida marinha
mas também na vida terrestre que nem a
degradação do solo a degradação do solo
é o processo pelo qual o solo vai se
esgotando perdendo os nutrientes
isso pode ser por uma semana e
inadequada ou simplesmente naturalmente
desmatamento o desmatamento é quando
você corta asa é as árvores de uma área
total ou parcial em segundo a lei você
tem que reflorestar mas você não
consegue reflorestar por causa da
degradação do solo porque as plantas têm
dificuldade em se desenvolver em solos
pouco ricos em nutrientes
outro tema que eu queria abordar era o
consumo excessivo de água que é uma
coisa que afeta o mundo inteiro e não só
uma região alerta segundo a onu em 2025
cerca de 1,1 bilhão de pessoas não vou
ter acesso a esse recurso que a água
potável isso quer dizer que o número de
doenças vão aumentar e não só na região
onde está atendendo à crise mas sim no
mundo inteiro que você está fazendo a
sua parte
você pode começar a fazer sua parte
simplesmente tomando banhos mais curtos
o pastor informação para seus
amigos e familiares você deve pensar
globalmente e agir localmente
obrigada pela atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]